the spider-man far from home trailer is
about to play but if you haven't seen
Avengers 2 endgame yet stop watching
because there's some serious spoilers
about to come up but if you have seen
Avengers endgame enjoy the trailer
everywhere I go I see his face listen
damn it son - I don't think Tony would
have done what he did if he didn't know
that you were gonna be here after he was
gone
you gonna be in exile and now well no I
don't have time I'm too busy doing your
jobs I'm kidding I'm kidding look keep
up the good work because I am going on
vacation
heads up Nick Fury's calling I don't
really want to talk to any computers all
why because if you don't talk to a man I
have to talk but I want to talk about
you sent Nick Fury to voicemail I got to
go you do not ghost Nick Fury dorks
what's up we're just talking about the
trip I'm here in say Marco Polo oh I
think I'm sure very likes me when I
first on alone you're a very difficult
person to contact spider-man this is mr.
Beck we're gonna use someone like you on
my world New Worlds Beck is from Earth
just not house a snap to our home in our
dimension we have a job to do you're
coming with us
it's gotta be something else you can use
what about Thor offworld captain burns
unavailable that push the friendly
neighborhood spider-man
[ __ ] please you've been to space what
do you want Peter
I want to go back on my trip with the
girl who I really like you tell her how
I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course not I
mean it's kind of obvious you're right
you may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
so I feel like I putting my friends to
danger
the world needs the next Iron Man you're
going to step up or not
[Music]
I'm outta here building jet I work with
spider-man do one for spider-man
I want what spider-man not for
spider-man
Thank You spider-man we're so good thank
sorry I'm late
happy nice thank you you too thank you
new dress yes it is hatching at all what
just happened
putting a trip go to Europe school trip
let's get your passport Peter Parker
here to pick up a passport please
ladies face let's move pack your suit I
just want to go on my trip with my
friends Europe doesn't really need it
from the neighborhood
you look really pretty therefore I have
value no it's not I'm messing with you
you look pretty too my personal love I
just finished my phone coffee so nice to
finally meet you
in spite of man
your Nick Fury what some clothes on
let's go for a ride
is she gonna be okay like that might
want to turn him over so he doesn't
swallow his tongue
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
get gifts Parker but a job to do
are you going to step up or not
you're all alone your friends are in
trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man Thor
rolled into one
he's no spider-man what is it with you
and spider-man what he looks out for the
neighbor it has a dope suit and I really
respect him
sup dickwad these no no banana great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
two weeks in Europe it's gonna be great
I'm just gonna enjoy my trip hang out
with MJ feel like really pretty
therefore I have value no no that's not
what I meant
I'm messing with you that's really nice
someone nice to finally meet you
spider-man hear Nick Fury put some
clothes on let's go for a ride
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
get gifts Parker but we have a job to do
are you going to step up or not
for all alone
and friends are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one he's no spider-man
what is it with you and spider-man what
he looks out for the neighbor it has a
dope suit in my really respective sub
loser
[Music]